hier des kilomètres de fils une course
contre la montre depuis quelques jours
cette entreprise ne connaît plus une
minute de répit
plutôt que les habituels chemise
qu'elles produisent les ouvrières se
sont mis à coudre des masques une fierté
pour ses petites mains on se réveille en
disant d'un voilà
on est utile on serre et notre usine qui
est là qui existe depuis 1947 qu'on a
tenu à flot du chocolat demain ben
et prend un sens jusqu'à 400 pièces
produites chaque jour beaucoup de
travail de nombreuses étapes et au final
un modèle qui présente l'avantagé d'être
réutilisable tous les basques sont
lavables ces trois 3 épaisseurs de tissu
100 % coton que nous avons rassemblé
ensemble en fait je suis parti du
principe que dans nos cols et poignets
de chemise
nous avions des tissus techniques entre
guillemets et donc c'est cela que j'ai
utilisée pour pour les la conception de
masquer des masques vendu à un prix
symbolique seulement de quoi payer les
coûts de production le patron est
assailli de demandes
vous les apporter à quelle heure depuis
vendredi le téléphone n'arrête pas de
sonner
effectivement que ce soit des ehpad des
hôpitaux et autres sociétés mais pour
l'instant la priorité est donnée au
centre hospitalier de chalon des
centaines de masques livrée par le
patron en personne